now the United Kingdom moved into
lockdown as one nation but one of the
big questions about the future is
whether restrictions could be eased at
different speeds in different areas
Wales for example has already announced
a mild easing of the lockdown from
tomorrow their first minister Mark Drake
furred got ahead of the prime minister
with that announcement and he joins us
now from Cardiff thank you very much for
being with us this morning and before we
get on to the easing of the lockdown I
just want to ask your opinion on the new
slogan from the government stay at home
has been replaced by a stay alert what
do you make of it well I think it is
important for people to stay alert
because coronavirus has quite certainly
not gone away and is going to be with us
for a long time ahead but I also think
that if people are not leaving home for
an essential purpose for exercise or to
go to work then people will still be
staying at home because the fewer
contacts you have with other people the
more you suppress your own risk and the
risk to others so being alert is
important but staying at home has not
gone away so you do think that the stay
at home element should have been
retained well I'm just saying that the
message I will be giving to people in
Wales is is while they must be alert to
the continuing danger of coronavirus if
you're not out of your house for an
essential purpose and that does include
exercise that can include shopping and
it can must include going to work for
people who can safely do so staying at
home remains the best way that you can
protect yourself and others now you have
already announced a slight easing or
tweaking if you like of the lockdown in
Wales are you were you expecting to hear
something similar from Boris Johnson
later today well it's for the prime
minister to make the decisions for
England not for me to advise him but his
official spokesperson has been
emphasizing the Prime Minister's view
that maximum caution is still required
at this point so I'm broadly expecting
that the review of the regulations in
England will continue to have that
incremental approach to lifting the
lockdown rather than rather than
anything more dramatic
and Robert Jenner it was just saying how
he hopes that all the different nations
will move in a similar way I just wonder
how has number 10 been when it comes to
keeping you informed
I mean do you actually know what Boris
Johnson is gonna say later uh no I don't
know we did have a discussion with
Michael Gove on Friday which was helpful
in illustrating some of the thinking
that's going on inside Downing Street
I've described the relationship with the
UK government as one of fits and starts
when we do it when there is engagement
it is good and it is helpful and I wish
there could be more of it because the
more we talk to each other the more we
share ideas and perspectives the better
the chance will be that we can do what
mr. generic referred to and which is my
ambition as well I think we are stronger
when we move together when we have a
fundamentally shared sense of what needs
to be done and the more we're able to
discuss that across the United Kingdom I
think the greater the chance of
achieving that becomes I do wonder if it
is a issue that you don't know what he's
going to say and would it be problematic
if as the lockdown becomes eased further
think we have different rules on
different sides of the England Wales
border well I don't want to see
fundamentally different rules because
that is confusing for people and it
makes the basic message hard to convey
there will always be fine-tuning that's
the nature of devolution for 20 years
we've had different rules on either side
of the border and actually people in
Wales are very used to this but I think
of that as I say as customizing a basic
UK wide approach so that it fits as best
we can make it here in Wales I think
that's how we've tried to do things over
the last six weeks I think broadly that
has been successful that's how I am
committed to trying to make sure we go
on into the future we could have some
pretty big differences they frankly
couldn't we and we don't know for
example what Boris Johnson is going to
announce on schools but there has been
some speculation that he may relaxed the
rules on some primary schools but use
that the Welsh schools won't be
reopening on the 1st of June I mean
these are
fundamental differences well that would
be a significant difference but it's not
an unprecedented one our school holidays
are different in Wales to England now
shut down a well our schools are not all
shut down our schools are opened now for
children of key workers and vulnerable
children with more children attending
school since the easter holiday and our
schools will remain open for those
purposes as we build back the school
population here in Wales we will do it
in discussion with the teacher unions in
discussion with local authorities and
very importantly in discussion with
parents as well and we'll make the
decisions that are right for Wales they
may be in a fine-tuned rate different
from what's happening across our border
but the direction of travel the wish to
begin to be able to use schools for more
children and to return more children to
school I think that will be a shared
ambition so if you send your children to
school over a border which government
should you listen to well my own view
will be you should listen to the
government of where you live I know
there are some differences we do have
some children who live in Wales and go
to school in England and live in England
go to school in Wales and those parents
will need to discuss that with their
head teachers and with their local
education Authority it's not a large
number and those parents are very used
to dealing with those sorts of
ambiguities and they do it by discussing
their own circumstances with the people
on the ground who are best place to
advise them and just finally be devolved
administrations are responsible for a
health policy but it's Westminster that
it is largely looks after the economy
and of course is running these very
expensive schemes on following workers
or laying out loans to businesses do you
think that that focus on health is
partly why it seems in some cases the
government's in Scotland and Wales have
been more cautious than that in
Westminster on easing the lockdown
well I think that what is good for
people's health is good for the economy
I don't believe in this oppositional
idea that you could trade one against
the other
we do the right things by public health
we will avoid a second peak of the virus
and the worst thing for our economy
would be to have a rapid restart now
followed by a rapid clamping down as
things get out of hand so my view has
always been you must attend to the
public health dimension because that is
the way in which we can provide a solid
platform for our economy to get back to
work and it's very important for all
sorts of reasons people's health as well
as their livelihoods but that should
take place as well okay mark would thank
you very much for coming on the program
today thank you thank you